le temps s'est arrêté.
Il n'y a plus que le bruit
résonnent et l'écho lointain
de la guerre. Tous les tableaux
ont été retirés. Le musée
"Ce que nous avons fait il
y a un mois
confie le directeur.tatatatatat,
de gravures et de sculptures
ont été retirés, soigneusement
emballés et cachés secrètement ,
parfois sous terre. L'opération
monumentale a pris dix jours.
Ihor Kozhan se f
de protéger le patrimoine de
son pays d'une posatatatattaque
russe.séséséséséséséséséséséséss
pièces uniques qui n'ont
prix. L'institution est reconnue
pour son imposante collect
patrimoniale, des icônes
médiévales, des gravures
folkloriques et des
Ici se
du 15e siècle. Ihor connaît
par coeur cececece qu'occupait
chaque oeuvre.
disparaître, aussi petite
soit-elle, ce serait une perte,
non seulement pour l'Ukraine,
du monde entier."
À quelques kilomètres
de là, les sirènes d'alerte
les cours de l'Académie
nationale des arts.
Mais les étudiants ici restent
déterminés à garder la création
bien vLeLeLeLeLes couleurs
de l'oeuvre de Katya sont
"Cette silhouette
orange incarne la douleur.
La guerre, aussi déchirante
soit-elle, est devenue
une source d'inspiration."
"Je suis triste, mais monststst
que jamais", dit-elle.
t t t t t t donner un souffle
nouveau à la culture",
"L'art est une preuve qstststs,
alors que les Russes tente
de nous détruire."
"Nous ne nous sommes jamais U e
depuis le début de la guerre."
Ihor, lui, se demanderrrrrrrrrr
ses tableaux à nouveau.
le nôtre, dit-il, c'est
dirérérérérérérévoir."
Il est impatient de revoir
ses
d'accueillir le public
à
"Pour exister, le musée
a be
et de ses visiteurs.
Sans ememememememememe
un entrepôt", dit-il.
Avant
notre interprète ukrainien,
Illia, ablblblblblblblbler
le vide à sa manière. ( ( ( ( (♪
Ici
Radio-Canada, Lvi